ask me about Matthew 2434 is that what
you want to ask me 34- 36 this
generation shall not pass until all
things things are fulfilled is that what
you want to ask me
yes what what what liberal Scholars like
Albert schweer talk about they try to
say that Jesus thought the end of the
world was gonna be in his time and why
should I care what Albert schwitzer
thinks you shouldn't but I'm just saying
who's who's making the claim that's all
a lot of people make a lot of claims
right right so the point is what's the
proof number one the assumption is that
when Jesus said this generation shall
not pass it's talking about his second
coming where he will return from heaven
and establish his kingdom on Earth and
he descends physically bodily for all to
see if you actually read Matthew 24 very
carefully and not simply take verses out
of statement the entire discourse
focuses focuses primarily on what if you
start from Matthew
2337 all the way 39 and then you go into
Matthew 24 what is Jesus addressing at
the start of the
chapter Matthew at the start of Matthew
23 yeah I mean if you go to Matthew 23
37-39 read that Jerusalem Jerusalem you
who killed the prophets and St these
you're reading too fast like if you're
trying to get to Mecca Jerusalem
Jerusalem you who killed the prophets
and ston those sent to you how often
have I have longed to gather your
children together together as a hen
gathers her chicks under her wings and
you were not willing look your house is
left to to you desolate for for I tell
you you will not see me again until you
say blessed is he who comes in the name
of the Lord now pause right there before
you go on he goes your house will be
left desolate what house is he talking
about I don't know the temple in
Jerusalem what other house was there in
Jerusalem oh so he talk about the
destruction of the temple yes and notice
what he says you will never see me again
unless you say blessed is he who comes
in the name of the Lord so my question
before we move on did they say as a
nation blessed is he Jesus who comes on
him Lord or they continue to reject
him who does he say must say this for
them to see him
again the Jews okay read it
again Jerusalem Jerusalem you who kill
the prophets and Stone Those sent to you
how often have I have longed to gather
your children together as a hen gathers
her chicks under her wings and you are
not willing who's not
willing Jerusalem you got it so
Jerusalem and then he says go on look
your house is left to you desol oh okay
so it's time by the temple yeah because
addressing Jerusalem by Jerusalem he's
referring to the religious
authorities those who control Jerusalem
the religious establishment the the
priests the Pharisees the scribes
Sanhedrin right
right right okay so what did he say to
them you will not see me again until you
say blessed is he who comes in name of
the Lord so did they ever say that or
did they continue to reject him they
contined to reject him until this Temple
was destroyed that's why they didn't see
him
again okay so he's not actually talking
about like the end times in this part
he's just talking about now continue
reading though to chapter 24 slowly keep
reading to 24 Jesus left the temple and
was walking away when his disciples came
up to him to call his attention to its
buildings to
what call his attention to the building
in Jerusalem the temple and the
buildings right right do you see all
these things he asked truly I tell you
not one stone here will be left on
another everyone will be thrown down
keep reading as Jesus was sitting on the
mountain of Olives the disciples came to
him privately tell us they said when
will this happen and what will be the
sign of your coming okay now that's the
okay
now that's the context the sign of your
coming and the end of the age now when
he says End of the Age what age are they
referring to are they referring to the
end of time as we know it using new
heaven or he's talking about the end of
the Old Testament
era oh okay I see so they're talking
about when he's gonna rise from the dead
and the old Covenant will be not only
rise no no he what did they just what
did he just say not one Temple when not
one what read it again not one not one
stone here will be left on another so
what are they asking
him about the destruction of the temple
so yeah what is the sign of you coming
to destroy the temple which signifies
the end of this era the end of the Old
Testament age the end of the Old
Testament era okay that makes sense all
right so did that generation pass away
or did that generation see the
destruction of Jerusalem and the temple
that generation saw the destruction the
temple so where is the false
prophecy there is none that's right
because the mistaken assumption is that
when Jesus says the son of man coming
that means a physical bodily coming
where we see it no often times Old and
New Testament will use the language of
God coming to destroy a nation without
you seeing God visibly to do
so oh okay so there so there's no false
prophecy because he wasn't even talking
about the end of end times not the end
the end of the age of
Jerusalem right yeah I was saying he's
not talking about the end times the end
of the age of Jerusalem let me show you
where let me show you
where GE where you'll find passages of
God coming to destroy a nation without
that meaning coming visibly where you
see him go to Isaiah 19 verse1 I'm there
read it for me see the Lord rides on a
swift cloud and is coming to Egypt the
idols of Egypt tremble before him and
the hearts of the Egyptians Melt With
Fear read one verse one one more time
slowly see the Lord rides on a swift
cloud and is coming to Egypt the idols
of Egypt tremble before him and the
hearts of the Egyptians Melt With Fear
this is talking about the Lord bringing
judgment in Egypt but did he ever come
physically bodily or visibly to do
that uh I don't actually don't know I'm
not going to say no he didn't
historically you won't hear the
Egyptians saying and the god of Israel
showed up visibly during the time of
Isaiah or even centuries after that even
at the time of Christ to do because it's
not talking necessarily of God appearing
visibly but when a nation is destroyed
because of its wickedness that's a sign
that God has come in
judgment okay so you with me so far yeah
so it's not necessarily always talking
about uh something physically happening
right what you're say coming to Jud a
nation so how do we know God came
because we see the effects we see
Jerusalem destroyed that means Jesus
came to judge
it oh okay I see we okay that makes
sense so when Jerusalem was destroyed
and the temple was destroyed that was
the sign that the apostles asked what is
the sign the sign that I've come to
destroy Jerusalem is when you see
Jerusalem and the temple destroyed by
the Romans did that
happen yes and that was the sign Jesus
came came in the Clouds Of Heaven to
destroy Jerusalem and the
temple okay that Mak sense now go to
Revelation 3 verses 1 or three to let's
show you another
example Revelation what chapter 3 verses
1 to
three okay read it for me to the angel
of the church in Sardis right these are
the words of him who holds the seven
spirits of God and the Seven Stars I
know your deed you have a reputation of
being alive but you are dead keep
breathing all the way to
three wake up strengthen what remains
and is about to die for I have H found
your Deeds unfinished in the sight of
God of my God remember therefore what
you have received and heard hold it fast
and repent but if you do not wake up I
will come like a thief and you do not
know what time I will come to you okay
now Jesus warns this church at Sardis if
you don't repent I will come against you
like a thief and remove you now that
church has been re removed that means
Jesus came and removed it right M but
did he come physically to do that did
anyone see Jesus come down physically no
you got it
now okay so this is basically it's when
a a prophecy can essentially be
fulfilled in Revelation but not the
whole thing yes because those churches
have been removed because he's also
threatening those churches five of which
are are dishonoring L he says if you
keep it up you will no longer be a lamp
before me I will remove you and that has
happened
historically okay that makes sense okay
so there's nothing in Matthew 24 3436
specifically 34 that says this is
referring to Jesus returning physically
bodily to establish his kingdom on Earth
the context guys why did you block love
and forgiven love and forgiven is asking
a genuine question I don't get it
Prophet Google take it easy buddy I know
you're sleep depraved the guy was asking
a legit question
there's nothing in the context that's
talk about Jesus's physical bodily
return it's talking about Jesus coming
to destroy Jerusalem and the temple
because of the Jewish religious
establishments rejection of
him okay that makes sense and that's why
what happened afterwards now let me show
you the Fulfillment of this passage go
down to Matthew 24 29- 31
immediately after the distress of those
days the sun will be darkened and the
moon will not give its light the Stars
will fall from the sky and Heavenly
Bodies will be sh when you say when it
says stars fall from the St Heavenly
Bodies people who do not understand
biblical language are assuming astral
objects no stars and Heavenly Bodies can
also refer to
principalities dominions and powers in
The Heavenly realm satanic powers that
will not be disarmed and destroyed
M you me
there yeah okay so keep
reading then we'll appear the sign of
the son of man in heaven sign of son of
man go uh and then all the peoples of
the earth will mourn when they see the
son of man coming on the clouds of the
heaven with proud with power and great
glory and he will send his angels with a
loud trumpet call and they will gather
his elect from the Four Winds from one
end of the Heavens to the other oh see
that clearly means his physical return
to the Earth no now let me break that
down he says when this happens then the
angels will be sent out to all four
corners of the earth to gather the elect
to Jesus
right yeah that's what you just read 31
right yep okay but let me tell you
something did you know the word
Angel doesn't mean necessarily a spirit
creature it can also referred to a human
agent a human messenger a human
messenger and you want proof of it in
Matthew
11:10 the prophecy about John the
Baptist where God says see I send my
messenger ahead of you the Greek word is
Angel and there it's referring to John
the Baptist what kind of Angel was John
the
Baptist uh human exactly so when Jesus
says I'm going to send Angels it doesn't
mean Spirit creatures it means I'm then
going to send my human angels to them
preach the gospel all over the world to
gather my elect by the preaching of the
Gospel that's exactly what happened the
gospel has been advancing to the Four
Winds of the Earth from that moment till
now okay that makes sense so none of
this is about the end the end times it's
about the preaching of the Gospel to me
when Jerusalem is destroyed that ushers
in the church
age and that church age will be
proclaimed by his human Angels
throughout the Four Winds to gather all
of them to Jesus by the proclamation of
the
Gospel makes sense